hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 1 hits the heroes with
uncomfortable realizations like how much
it sucks to have your pet stare at you
while you have sex i thinks we're
fighting or like belated or something
and these in-depth breakdowns I dive
into interesting parallels hidden
meanings darker theories the kind of hot
takes to get you to peek over that
cubical wall and say I figured out what
the night King meant by that human meat
spiral um this is an open plan office
and HR put you in a cubicle for a reason
so please stop talking to me let's dive
into what you might have missed this
episode boiler warning if you haven't
seen the episode yet and let's start
with this new opening title sequence
last season ended with the geography of
Westeros as we knew it changing the most
dramatically since the children the
forests sunk the land bridge between the
continents thousands of years ago yep
that's the kind of nurture we're gonna
get into a lot of these breakdowns
so show producers must have felt like
map makers 1991 after the Berlin Wall
fell probably update this the wall is
now collapsed at Eastwatch and the
ground flips over blue like a game board
to signify the White Walkers progress
and now we see the interior of a lot of
locations including the Great Hall and
the crypts of Winterfell showing the
Statue of Lyanna stark that will play a
big role later on this episode and the
red cape in the dungeons beneath showing
Qyburn scorpion weapon aimed at dragon
skulls all interspersed with these new
tableaus of key events like the red
wedding and the birth of Daenerys
dragons I'm actually gonna make a whole
other video breaking down these new
titles and what they could mean for this
final season so keep an eye out for it
but the opening shots of this episode
introduce us to this unnamed northern
boy witnessing the arrival of Daenerys
army through the streets of winter town
the neighboring village just outside
Winterfell someone in the crowd steps
aside to give him room and that someone
is Arya Stark she smiles because this
boy is the first of many callbacks to
the first episode of the series all the
way back in 2011 which of course showed
the arrival of King Robert Baratheon
Arya was once just like this young kid
super pumped to see this new arriving
monarch and all the weirdos who get
dragged along in addition to mirroring
Arya as a face in the crowd
the boy also mirrors bran as well
climbing into the top of a tree for a
better look the way brand climbed to the
top of the tower of Winterfell to save
Robert and his army back in that scene
bran said the interesting line
a line that would foreshadow bran in
this moment seeing a different King
marching toward Winterfell depicting
this opening arrival once again through
the eyes of children reminds us who the
real victims are of this coming conflict
the youth those who should have their
whole lives in front of them live sex
should last longer than five more
episodes there's an even more subtle
callback with the music of the scene
this merge is composed of Ramin Djawadi
same score for the arrival of Robert
Baratheon
notice that javadi made a little
adjustment to the Baratheon marched
theme mixes in those two notes of an
upright bass which is from the Daenerys
theme you may remember it's scoring the
moment Daenerys acquired this unsullied
army back in esta por so Danny's music
underscoring Roberts music reflects her
victory over him here I'll call back to
Robert in the Winterfell crypts from
that first episode who swore death to
the surviving Targaryen specifically
Dany it's done you grace tell Gary ins
are gone I'll just followed by a jump
cut to Danny then various calls out
tyrion lanister on all of his eunuch
jokes and Tyrians response actually gets
kind of a rimshot from the horse behind
them because I have bowls you didn't I
first said that this was very weird
source and he'd be like yeah I feel that
that'd be nothing I don't feel anything
on my back but actually it's the horse
of one of the Dothraki bloodrider x' as
they all face the judgmental scales of
the northern people John reminds
Daenerys that they don't trust outsiders
a few of them are older with even older
grumpier scales than the rest probably
old enough to remember Daenerys his
father the Mad King Aerys the second who
executed Ned Stark's father ricard stark
and his brother Brandon Stark they may
also be aware of the ancient history of
Tauron Stark the king who knelt who
surrendered the north to Aegon the
conquerer so Daenerys is marching into a
millennia-old chorus of get off my lawn
inside the walls of Winterfell John
reunites with bran saying he's a man now
and bran responds almost as in this was
almost not awkward
bran is suggesting that he's not fully
human anymore that's like two preceding
three-eyed Raven his
mind and body are becoming linked with
the roots of the magical rear wood trees
that span Westeros and give him his
visions John hug Sansa asking which are
you looking this is another callback to
the first episode where Catelyn s Sansa
the same question yes uh-huh
Sansa where's your sister Arya is
missing again here for the same reason
she prefers to be a face in the crowd
the many-faced God incarnate and she
wants to be the one who can get the
first look as opposed to lining up with
everyone else in being seen John
introduces Daenerys as Queen Daenerys of
House Targaryen and immediately that
earns him a bitter snarl from the young
Lyanna Mormont and from young Ned umber
a little huh again the youth response is
key here because they see the world in
the simplest terms in this world is
really theirs to inherit and Sansa
greets Daenerys with a specific phrase
Winterfell is you know crazy
that's exactly how Ned greeted Robert in
the first episode nine years why I'm not
seeing you where the hell have you been
guarding the north for you your grace
Winterfell is yours Sansa shows that she
has learned in the art of diplomacy
despite harboring mistrust of this
foreign Queen which she later reveals
with some side eye these are all
political tactics that she learned from
Petyr Baelish tried every battle
everywhere always in your mind everyone
is your enemy every one of your friend
live that way and nothing will surprise
you back in the parallel scene of the
first episode every stark that King
Robert touched later died Ned Catelyn
robb and Rickon the characters who
avoided Robert's death touch survived
Sansa Arya bran and John it's possible
that Daenerys could also be a sign of
doom but she's looking to touch any one
be his brand puts a stop to these
pleasantries ain't nobody got time for
this so in the meeting hall Sansa
singles out young Ned umber who leans
over nervously like the kid in class who
doesn't want to get called on when we're
back in the season 7 premiere John Ford
gave this boy along with the head of
house car start Alice actually shows up
later this episode Ned umber stumbles
over how to address Sansa and John and
Danny we need more horses and wagons if
it please my lady and my lord and my
queen
sorry next time kid just shouts where
all my wagons
Ned along with Lyanna Mormont are
reminders that children are running
these major northern houses and in this
scene the whole room speaks through the
mouths of these two babes confusion of
her John's relationship with Danny and a
little pissed off if their king into
North bent the knee
Tyrion tries to reassure everyone but
he's met with a glare from Lord yon
Royce who later gave him a big yeah no
thanks when Tyrion approached him in
Santa his hatred of Tyrion goes all the
way back to season one
remember when Tyrion insulted lady Arryn
and the entire Vale including Lord Royce
by buying his way out of a trial by
combat by using grande as Tyrion
explains a dilemma he's framed with
Santa over one shoulder and Daenerys
over the other employing in his duel
loyalties now the show is actually gives
similar angels on the shoulders framing
before with Ned Stark
in the first episode Catelyn framed
behind one shoulder of maester Luwin
framed behind the other again the man in
the middle here is torn between his
affections in his duties and Sansa
always a pragmatist reminds us that this
new army and Dragons gotta eat what the
dragons eat anyway and the camera does a
subtle focus shift to Daenerys in the
background who responds whatever they
want and then Danny turns to meet
santa's eyeline the words themselves are
simple but the focus pole and the
gesture by Daenerys underlined this
response as a threat my dragons could
just eat you lady
after this Tyrion catches up with Sansa
reminding each other the last time they
saw each other at Joffrey's wedding
slash murder or as it's called in
Westeros just a wedding
Sansa jokes it had its moments but
Tyrians joyless reaction of this reminds
us that while Joffrey's death was kind
of a victorious escape for Sansa
criterion and led to the darkest moments
of his life such as Casa Tyrion for
trusting Cersei to help them and Tyrion
catch his brand creepily staring up at
him from the courtyard below perhaps
asking him to design some wheelchair
ramps to go along with that special
saddle he made for him perhaps bran has
seen some greater role for Tyrion than
these mere political squabbles moving on
to the Winterfell godswood where Arya
finally reunites with Jon saying he used
to bitola another parallel to Robert's
reunion with Ned and the pilot go fat in
both cases this teasing leads to a
loving hug oh but yeah
not exactly on the same page you could
also see this scene as parallel to the
moment that Catelyn met with Ned in the
same location in the first episode where
in both of these scenes the man had his
Valyrian steel sword unsheathed John
asked ow Arya snuck up on him in the
Arya asked how he survived a knife
through the heart to which he says yeah
wait did I answer my question with a
question smartass also I didn't both
characters were marking on the other's
dramatic change Arya has transitioned
from a heavy-footed stopper that she was
in season 1 - and a July water dancer
and John is resurrected which honestly
isn't talked about enough by these
characters like Ned and Robert this
reunion is less formal than it is
teasing and friendly kind of like bro e
warriors then of the fact that they
compared their sword lengths
John gave Arya her sword needle in
season 1 and now he asks her if you've
used it once or twice yeah more like
four or five times Arya she used it on a
stableboy and sees one polliver and
roars in season 4 and of course on the
wait in season 6
but Argus reaction to John's Valyrian
steel sword Longclaw is more interesting
to me she says daddy faith it's an odd
thing to say because Valyrian steel is
famously lighter and weight than
ordinary steel I think there's more
symbolic weight to Arya's words here she
could be suggesting that the weight of
John's responsibilities is too heavy for
her and rather than joining him in this
confrontation with a knight King
directly maybe she has a different
mission on her mind more on that later
but moving on to King's Landing where
Cersei Lannister learned from Qyburn
that the White Walkers have broken
through the wall and responds perfectly
in character
this smugness is exactly how Cersei
reacted to the last horrific catastrophe
the explosion of the Sept of Baelor by
wildfire Cersei his pure schadenfreude
delighting and others misfortune and we
should definitely fear what other
atrocities she might let transpire
perhaps burning down the rest of King's
Landing with wildfire as well or maybe
joining forces with the knight king
you're on Greyjoy's iron fleet arrives
in the Blackwater Bay carrying the
golden company led by Captain Strickland
you're on holds captive is nice you're a
Greyjoy talking to her because his crew
is composed of mutes remember when
you're on sacks Beyond and Yara's group
in season seven his men cut out the
tongues of the ones they defeated this
is a
from the books Euron Greyjoy is an
insanely brutal pirate hoody tongues his
crew to keep them from mutinying against
him thus his ships name the silence
considering all the torture you're on
famously puts on his captives it's
actually pretty surprising Yara isn't in
worse shape than she is but it's also
worth noting that cutting out their
tongues also prevents his crew from
reporting an attack which Theon does
later this episode so this reminder of
his muted crew also reminds us of his
vulnerability in the red cape Cersei
receives the biggest disappointment of
this episode that the golden company
best known for having their awesome war
elephants left them at home that's
disappointing
I was told the golden company had
elephant yeah we were all told there
would be elephants and the words apart
Simpson seriously you couldn't cut out
like 30 seconds of that How to Train
Your Dragon flight montage and giving us
one damn elephant and there's some
background here in the golden company
the golden company is an army of cell
swords from Essos who were founded by
house Blackfyre a line of Targaryen
bastards who tried to seize the iron
throne in the Blackfyre rebellion so
maybe leading the elephants behind
suggests some kind of secret plan to
betray Cersei maybe support a Targaryen
retaking the throne then we catch up
with Bronn rolling the sheets with some
hopefully well-paid women this is the
first time in a long time that we've had
a non romantic mood seen on the show
plus one I can remember is season five
with the sand snakes and Bronn always
seems to be around for these so this
poor Nissin seems like another parallel
to the opening episode remember the
scene with Roz in Tyrion these women are
gossiping about the death and
disfigurement of Lannister soldiers
referring to last season's deadly Battle
of Blackwater rush in Episode four when
many of them were cooked in their armor
by drogon and bran reminds him of his
badassery in that battle keeping the
dragon from doing even more damage
operating that big scorpion weapon now
one of the soldiers they mentioned
should sound pretty familiar to him
boyacky the ginger that's him
came back with his face burn right off
he's got no eyelids now so yeah a
Lannister soldier a ginger named Eddie
folks they're talking about ed sheeran
remember his character last season
singing a song about how a woman's hands
are warm hopefully there's still some
warm hands
therefore never blinking ed sheeran
Qyburn passes on an assignment to bran
from Cersei to kill both her brothers
Tyrion and Jaime using a familiar
crossbow she has a keen sense of poetic
justice this crossbow is the same one
that Tyrion ooz to murder their father
Tywin Lannister back in season 4 and
Cersei decided to bring it back here
echoes her poetic justice on the sand
snakes murdering one of them with a
poisoned kiss
revenge for them killing her daughter
Marcella with a poisoned kiss now why
does Cersei let urine have sex with her
well it could just be that she's looking
for a release now that Jaime's no longer
in her life
or perhaps she's looking for a powerful
figure whom she can say is the father of
her unborn child and secure her line of
succession and thus her own power
then again Cersei is drinking wine in
the scene something she knows pregnant
women shouldn't really do since
remembers she actually refused wine from
Tyrion when she told him she was
pregnant last season here you're on rubs
her abdomen and says oh yeah real
charmer you would think Cersei would be
showing by now you're not have enough
time to go to Essos and back and if she
really was pregnant don't you think
you're on would have felt kind of a bump
there so I think what many of us have
been speculating it's possible that
Cersei was lying about her pregnancy and
maybe here she's using sex to were
you're on into a trap maybe a trap that
ends with the mountain ripping his balls
off
pay off his joke about having balls
earlier whatever her exact plan is I
don't think she wants to end up with
anyone as she suggested - you're on in
the scene no I want to be a nod while
urines distracted Theon rescues Yara and
they escape as Yara heads back to the
Iron Islands and beyond to Winterfell
they repeat the chant of the drowned God
that's who's dead may never die
we kill the bastards anyway the Ironborn
worship the drowned God and when they
baptize each other they drown people in
seawater forcing the baptized to cough
up the water and return harder and
stronger they believe and byyyeeeee are
adding this last line but kill the
bastards anyway she's linking their
religious belief with the magic of the
white walkers who have demonstrated an
actual ability to resurrect the dead and
she's warning Theon that the threat
they're facing is a godly one to them
back in Winterfell the three wise men
Tyrion various sensor Davos Seaworth
discussed the northern power struggle
you want their loyalty you have to ruin
it you may remember earlier Cersei told
you're on a similar thing about earning
things you want to who'll buy one you
want a queen also of course Tyrion and
you're on both bragged about having
balls this episode it's just interesting
to me that they were being painted with
a similar brush both are Outsiders
trying to woo prizes you're on surprises
Cersei Tyrians prize I guess he's trying
to woo that Silver Fox Lord Royce it
ought to be interesting to see what
costs these two have to pay to get the
respect that they seek now these three
wise men stare at John and Danny and
start shipping them in their
imaginations they do make a handsome
couple this is another parallel to the
first episode remember when Cersei and
Catelyn watched their young lovers from
a distance Sansa and Joffrey match
making them into the future king and
queen consider now that worked out maybe
this parallel paints John and Daenerys
as a similarly doomed couple Varys
actually echoes this pessimism with an
interesting observation respect is how
the young keep us at a distance so we
don't remind them of an unpleasant truth
what does that nothing lasts maybe Marus
is saying that this love between John
and Daenerys will last or maybe he's
just still salty over Melisandre warning
him that he would die on Westeros last
season definitely the kind of thing
they'll put you in a bad mood for a
while John and Daenerys finally get some
alone time checking in on the Dragons
drogon and rag all whose appetites have
dwindled down to only 18 goats and 11
sheep yet when I eat that much people
call me a fatso or a werewolf Daenerys
blames the fact that the dragons don't
like it in the North this could be a nod
to Westeros see history when the
Targaryen Queen Allison visited
Winterfell on dragon back butter the
dragon strangely refused to fly north of
the wall
Daenerys dragons have already flown
north of the wall remember to save John
and the others last season but this
could imply the magic of the White
Walkers weakens the effectiveness of the
dragons here in the north now there's
even more significance to this moment
but this whole backstory about the
Targaryen ancestors was something that I
learned from some really really
interesting game of Thrones material
which I discovered through audible thank
you to audible for sponsoring this video
audible has an insane selection of audio
books including George RR Martin's
entire a Song of Ice and Fire series
it's how I review the books to prep for
this final season but also related
titles like the world of Ice and Fire
the untold history of Westeros and the
game of Thrones which goes into the past
of all these characters and all these
locations containing potentially some
huge clues for how this series could end
you can listen to audible while
commuting cooking cleaning in the
waiting room at the gaim let's guy me
yeah I'm just kidding I know I gotta hit
the gym to shut up all you cyber bullies
you know what I'm gonna do while I'm
blasting those glutes I'm gonna smash
that audible app button and listen to my
favorite audiobooks you can start
listening with a 30-day audible trial
and your first audiobook plus two
audible originals are free just go to
audible.com slash new rock stars again
audible.com slash new rock stars
AUD ible comm slash in ewr Ock St ARS or
text the word new rockstars all one word
- 500 500 alright back to John with
Marisa nor dragons in the scene John
finally mounts a dragon becoming the
Dragon Rider we've all been waiting them
to become and remember this is something
raggle only allows him to do because
John has Targaryen blood something he
realizes at the end of this episode and
this is especially significant because
Ragle was named after john's biological
father
Daenerys his brother Rhaegar Targaryen
John Leeson heiress to this waterfall
and really everything about this scene
suggests that this is one last moment of
happiness for these two doomed lovers
really just because no one on Game of
Thrones gets be too happy for too long
also it might be because this kind of
feels like an echo of John's past
relationship with Ygritte in season 3
Ygritte brought John to another northern
waterhole and we know how that
relationship ended that's right Holly
blocked as John keeps his Queen warm so
warm the Dragons keep staring
maybe the dragons are feeling awkward to
see their mom with this new guy he'll
never be our day
or maybe they know that these two are
actually related and then I'll never
work or who knows maybe that makes it
hotter for the Dragons now it's also
possible that since drogon was named
after Daenerys his ex-husband called
Drogo but were seen here as Drogo's
jealous spirit haunting the new
boyfriend another theory is that this
stair could be linked with other creepy
stairs this episode the stairs from bran
Stark perhaps he has warmed into the
mind of the dragon and this would be
another parallel with the first episode
in which bran is once again witnessing a
queen engaged in an incest okay down in
the forges of Winterfell ginjury forges
disease dragonglass arrow heads despite
how hot it must be beside those furnaces
when he exhales his breath is still
visible just an interesting detail to
establish how freaking cold this winter
must have gotten the Hound shows up they
get up a battle ax with a dragonglass
blade runs into Arya you left me to die
fast I roped you it's just interesting
that the Hound describes their partying
of ways like this because he's not
really mad that Arya left him to die
who's mad that she left him to die
slowly on his own as opposed to putting
him out of his misery like he told her
to do and another interesting detail as
the Hound marches up to Arya a jet of
steam hisses from the furnace reflecting
the hot anger between these two and
speaking a steamy once the Hound leaves
things really heat up between re and
ginjury I mean you look good once well I
guess a few sparks do show up later when
Arya turns back gives country that smile
and when Guidry teases her by Konnor
Lady Stark and as you wish my lady
calling back that sweet moment between
them in season two I should be calling
you milady if these two do end up
together this would be another nod to
the first episode when Robert told Ned I
have a son you ever do listen it will
join our houses but rather than Joffrey
and Sansa the son of the daughter could
end up being Gendry and Arya sure
ginjuries still technically a bastard
but there are ways he could be
legitimized but most important of this
scene is the new weapon aurilla test
skin jury to make for her the design
that she draws shows a spear and that
she wants one side headed with a dragon
glass blade but also so that the spirit
can detach into two parts maybe the
other side will contain her Valyrian
steel dagger and she'll have the staff
with like two different ways to kill
white walk
actually in this week's Westeros weekly
Q&A we speculated what this weapon could
be and what famous historical relics it
could be based on but I'm thinking Aria
just wants a more adaptable weapon
similar to the bo staff that she trained
with in Braavos and not like Jon's
long-lost sword that she has to confront
and lead the northers head on but rather
a weapon that she could be more nimble
and on her own with later on Dany and
joram eat with Samwell Tarly but Sam
also learns that Daenerys executed both
his father randyll Tarly and his younger
brother Dickon after they refused to
bend the knee and kudos to John Bradley
for the subtle variation in his
emotional responses to the death of his
father who was cruel to him and his
response to his brother whom he always
got along with in the courtyard
Sam noticed his brand staring Adam who
is he out here still and before Sam even
tells him why he's upset bran
immediately says it's time to tell John
the truth he trusts you more than anyone
see I think brand new Sam would learn
this upsetting news about his family and
now he's using Sam's emotional state to
get him to tell John the truth about his
identity bran knows it's better for Sam
to deliver this bad news
since John's more likely to trust his
longtime friend rather than a vacant
tree boy also of course bran says that
he's waiting for an old friend we
learned later that that old friend is
Jamie Lannister
I'm predicting that Sam will be more
forgiving of Jamie for shoving him out a
window even if the way he says old
friend sounds a lot like Hannibal Lecter
I'm having an old friend now down in the
crypts we get more parallels to the
pilot instead of Robert Ned at Lee
Anna's tomb now it's John and Sam at
Ned's tomb setting this moment at the
feet of Ned Stark's statue is symbolic
for a few reasons first it's an
interesting callback to meds final words
to John next to Lucy each of them took
about a month
now this isn't technically then next
time they saw each other John has the
down the crypts since that moment but
it's nonetheless a proper place for John
to learn who his mother really was it's
also interesting to see how both John
and Sam are carrying the legacy of Ned
Stark in different ways Sam is a Ned
figure in the way that he feels anger
over his father and his brother being
burned alive by a Targaryen monarch
meanwhile John is facing the pressure of
Ned Stark's lie the lie to keep his
identity a secret and ignore the
rightful lineage to protect the overall
realm a lie that John might have to
continue to keep now the camera stays on
John's bay
as he learns the truth and he struggles
in denial but then when his mother Liana
gets mentioned Liana statue appears in
the background just out of focus Jon's
placement in front of each of these
statues reflects his transition
throughout the scene beginning believing
that Ned was his father in Indiana that
Liana was his true stork connection and
from Ned's grave we move on to the grave
of another Ned poor Ned umber whose
namesake wasn't Ned Stark earlier Sansa
sent young Ned back to the umber home of
last hearth to bring his people back and
knowing Westeros geography last hearth
is the closest castle to the wall where
the White Walkers were last spotted so
this was probably going to end in a
similar way as her home did tormund
Giantsbane and beric Dondarrion still
alive they run into dollar as' ed in the
few remaining brothers of the Nights
Watch from Castle black
he's got blue eyes blue eyes yeah
hormones blue eyes remind us of his Lou
eye beauty and he wants to make
monstrous giant babies with yellow hair
eyes told us woman you've ever seen that
leads to the creepy reveal of young Ned
Humber's body surrounded by severed
limbs all arranged in the spiral pattern
another nod to the pilot which opened
with the White Walkers staged in a
similar massacre and this is the
creepiest moment I have seen on Game of
Thrones in recent memory
young Ned's eyes silently opening how to
focus behind torment or he suddenly
comes to life screaming and trying to
stab them so barracks says that this is
a message from the night king but what
does this message mean well let's zoom
an enhance on this crime scene that's
right it's CSI new rock stars
I guess the night Kings got this kid's
number
visible sunglasses so the night cane has
used this specific spiral pattern before
with the severed horse parts at the fist
in season 3 and in season 6 we learned
that this is actually originally a
symbol of the children of the forest who
created the night king as a weapon
during their war with the first men if
you look at this the night King has
actually recreated his origin with Ned
umber here Ned is impaled through the
chest at the center of the spiral just
as the night king was impaled at the
center of a spiral when he was created
now this fire was simple showed up again
in season seven in the caves of
Dragonstone along with another children
of the forest symbol the bisected circle
which was the pattern for the massacre
in the pilot episode perhaps the night
king is saying that he's seeking revenge
against the children of the forest for
cursing him into existence and he's
using their symbols as a warning for
that but I also want to point out that
the night king also did this to a young
boy now one of the few things we know
about the night King is that Craster
used to give him male babies which the
night king then transformed into the
white Walker race Gillies baby young-sam
was promised to the White Walkers and he
even came looking for him but they never
got there
could the message here be a demand for
tribute by the night king people of
Westeros give me your firstborn sons
your babies
berrak torches a spiral creating a
literal last hearth on the wall and
someone said that this fiery spiral
resembles the sigil of House Targaryen a
three-headed dragon with its legs and
its tail in a similar spiral I don't
know if that was intentional but what if
the baby - the night king once most of
all is a Targaryen remember back in the
moment that drogon stared at John and
Danny together perhaps the dragon's eyes
were actually being seen through by the
night king who supposedly does have the
ability to ward maybe this was the night
king watching as the baby he's always
wanted gets one step closer to being his
like I know that there is a bit out
there but in a way this horror with
young Ned umber is meant as a warning
that echoes the opening scene of the
series and a worst-case fate that could
await the main characters and this
brings us to the final scene the arrival
of Jaime Lannister at Winterfell
in the first episode his arrival in the
Winterfell courtyard was more proud
showboating now his face is covered and
his appearance is Haggard he's really
just another face in the crowd
no one recognizes him except bran in a
perfect callback to the final shot in
the pilot episode these two are reunited
the camera even Russia
in towards brands body as the boy
crashes back into Jamie's world a call
back to the way brand crashed into the
world in his fall and now instead of
brand being terrified as he was pushed
Jamie is the one who looks terrified and
bran just stares peacefully with a calm
look on his face that almost says the
things all do for love with a thing that
he does for love maybe being forgiveness
for this redeemed sinner ending with
this image of brand echos the opening
imagery of the unnamed northern boy the
passion of young Lyanna Mormont in the
sacrifice of young Ned umber it is the
youth who matter the most in this world
of Game of Thrones and it is the youth
who will decide what comes next do you
think bran should forgive Jamie what do
you think the night Kings symbol really
means comment with your thoughts and
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at ei
vas subscribe to new rockstars on
YouTube and subscribe to our podcast
feed Westeros weekly if you haven't
already to get early access to all of
our Game of Thrones coverage thanks for
joining me and could someone please
Weill brand back inside he's not a tree
yet
[Music]